e
e e
on the time being
10:04 we will get going on our work
session on um Revenue
estimates so I think um today and thank
you uh Chris for um giving us
a an updated
list that shows not only the business
taxes and and dras but also the the ones
that we went over yesterday um is there
anything you want to say about this
before I um start no I just want to make
sure everybody has it it's dated
February 11th um as the chair mentioned
page three is that uh sheet that takes
the dr's information from
yesterday um for 25 well I see an error
already so the first A and B is fiscal
25 C n d is 26 and enf are 27
okay um so it takes the the numbers that
were provided for 25 the low and the
high and then it takes the percentages
that were offered um in their
information and applies it to those you
can see where the meals and rooms
there's a gross number so that's the
400 uh almost $500 million and then from
that there's um the municipal transfer
and the school building Aid that's
removed and the net number is the number
that would be going to the general fund
and the education trust fund so when
you're doing your estimate related to
that um you want to focus on the gross
number and then once you get that I will
do a calculation
um that will make the adjustment and and
then let you know what the final number
is um the other thing is interest in
dividends you'll see that the number is
134 for fiscal year 25 in both the A and
the B uh columns the commissioner
mentioned that to you yesterday that she
thinks that's what the number is and
then in um fiscal year 26 the amount
would be
8.7 um and that and that's just due to
the timing of a fiscal year versus a tax
year being completed in in the
extensions
right and then the last uh note was just
with the real estate transfer again you
do a gross number and we deduct $5
million as um from that that gets
transferred to the affordable housing
Fund in the body of the um
spreadsheet you know Pages four to the
end you'll find shaded columns those are
the columns that you agreed to yesterday
columns that are in white are the
columns that you're going to work on
today if there's any changes or errors
in the Shaded columns let me know if for
somehow I that fingered a number and
didn't get it correct and you just
notied that please please let me know
that um the other thing that I did
provide you today is a print out of an
email I forwarded you the email as well
but it was to the insurance department
it's their response to the two questions
I posed to them yesterday one was that
they um factor in the the
disasters around the the country and
World in terms of their premiums and
were they satisfied with their um
estimates and so they gave you about a
page of of dialogue related to that the
short answer is yes and yes to both of
those questions right and I'm
comfortable with their response but
representative ORS isn't here for me to
say that so
okay thank you Chris all right
let's let's do what we did yesterday for
a little while anyhow work work
backwards so I'm going to go back to
um well actually let's see where's the
insurance page two or page four page
four yeah yeah let's go to page four
insurance tax
okay so and I forget who had those
questions but um the you had them okay
so you're okay now okay
um so then let's look at column F line
11 that number would be
1503 line 16 column
F
159.000 and line 21 163.05
if possibly could
happen to to which health fund I'm sorry
uh the in DJ's letter he spoke
to health and life guarantee fund
assessment
credit oh no I can't I I don't know how
they I don't know how they do that um
you know in terms of the cred sure they
delet but that's I thought you were
going towards the uh Medicaid expansion
fund
that's the the the guaranteed credit
thing I that I can't speak to the other
one I might have been able to speak to a
little bit I have no idea what that is
or how that applies or and no one's at
any rate thank you Mr chair yes and he's
concerned about uh raising the estimate
so I mean taking that into account we
will not raise the estimate be my
impression uh or my thought um
um any other any any other thoughts or
comments on that insurance uh column
column
F okay would someone what's that thank
you Mr Speaker quick recap was a good
bad and different it's you have a letter
in front of you from the insurance uh
commissioner it's self-explanatory he's
basically agreeing and saying that the
numbers he gave us he feels comfortable
with excellent thank you
so all right so um would someone like to
make a motion to uh accept
these represent Aly do I have a second
second
represent all right any further
discussion seeing none all in favor of
uh our our estimates for column F
insurance tax raise your hand
all
opposed all right um how many people do
we have here right now one two three
four five six seven eight 9 10 11 12
16 16 to
zero okay
next let's
let's look at
um
see let's uh look at uh utility property
tax on Page Six
yeah okay this is the the first one
we're addressing now where
we have highs and high and lows that are
not the same or not super close to each
other
um any comments on utility property tax
represent
elme thank you um
the utility property tax is on it's a
property tax it's not on the revenues of
those
organizations uh
and we are likely to see
some reduction in those properties from
the side of renewable energy given
what's going on nationally and uh and in
in the St
committee um and I don't see any reason
why the the other structures that bring
oil and gas into our state uh are going
to need more
infrastructure so I don't
really
understand um an increase
but uh there is
um a assessment Bureau inside the Dr
which doesn't ever talk to
us or to anybody else as far as I can
tell and
um maybe we could get an explanation out
of
them out of Dr yeah out out of out of
that part of
Dr it's kind of a
separate body inside every time I ask if
we could get some help from them
on they sort of refer us to the top
assessor so uh what is your so what is
your actual what is the specific
question well uh they're increasing the
value at the low level even I think oh
no no it's at uh the cafer is coming in
at 46.8 so um so they are taking it
down um yeah and they are actually their
High estimate is
below so it's probably a reflection
reflection of reality at this point it
seems like they're taking that into
account yeah yeah so I I take that back
sorry wasn't looking at the cafer all
right uh other
comments okay how about um suggestions
on what we've got FY 25 obviously line
11 line 16 and line 21 to fill in so U
this is not as simple as before where we
just uh round um so how do people feel
about this any any thoughts on what
these numbers should be for 25 26 27
represent of
YY the the bureau and Dr um it's been
pretty accurate when they uh presented
in the uh Science and Technology uh
group last year that's going to be
presenting a bill today I think
uh the figures for the fixed items the
property that is uh this this body
worked on uh uh PAB bramy uh chaired a
couple of different commit committees to
set the prices for the C cables the
conduits the the physical stuff that
gets power into your house not the
electrons but the the physical stuff
that may be subject to some
modifications with the the steel tariffs
that have been put on uh the aluminum uh
tariff that's put on because a lot of
the cable is not steel it's aluminum or
not the transmission lines are aluminum
but nevertheless I think that there may
be a a a shortterm
impact over the budget years two years
but for our
purposes I kind of believe that these
numbers are pretty
moderate concern Contin uh concerning
the the fluctuations that could take
place that is they
reflect a
median activity or valuation rather than
massive
swings in addition the consumption of
energy in the United States in New
Hampshire is
huge uh
so the dollar value coming in is only
going to go up but for budgeting
purposes I think we should probably stay
close to those provided by uh
Dr uh I think they've got a good handle
on okay where it's going to be thank you
well that's that's so just to finalize
that thought um you you think those are
pretty good where it's a high and a low
so where do you personally feel like it
should end
up 45 uh average it two yeah yeah 452
three somewhere in there okay uh
representative Southworth yes that's
what I had 45 micro microphone sorry 452
452 and that's the average of those two
numbers corre okay oh yes I see that now
452 okay any other thoughts or everyone
good with
452 question Mr chairman can the Dr just
give us maybe a number on the
depreciation every year
that these companies utilities go
through do you have
any depreciation numbers there on their
property the
property well let me just ask this I
mean when an assessor
assessor assesses a property they don't
take depreciation into
account so I'm not sure that that
matters yes okay representative tney
microphone please yes they do take into
account the age of a property uh if your
house is assessed and you've got a brand
new one out it's going to have uh one
rate and then uh one of the columns they
use is age of the property uh and that
can be a plus or a minus depending
upon just how how good the property is
okay and you know how fancy and all that
sort of stuff but yeah age does get
taken into account on it okay so age
gets taken into account however we're
talking about the next two years I mean
how big a change that's not going to be
big right there's there's not much of a
a change there so I I'm not sure it
makes sense for Dr to look at that
uh yes represent
opal I'm just I'm just trying to
understand ba based on listening to
representative Aly and I I think I agree
there's there's not going to be a whole
influx of infrastructure in the next two
years um if if the act for says
now um or at least that's projection for
for fiscal
24 what is the what are the fact factors
that we
think other than just trying to be
conservative that would reduce that
amount in fiscal 25 to the 45 the
average of the of the high and low
estimates just it's it's yeah it's um we
we haven't found that crystal ball so
yeah I know if it seems like there's a
little bit of guesswork there is but
it's based it's it's it's based on our
best thoughts about where we see things
heading I mean even if there is infrastr
I mean you could debate whether
infrastructure is going to decrease or
increase or where it's going to end up
but but even in that regard these are
these are big uh companies they're slow
moving sort of things so I don't think
you're going to see anything too
dramatic which is which is what I'm
wondering Mr chair that um you know
based on based on all of those factors
and what I understand I mean I'd be
comfortable with sort of going with the
with the a for number for all three
years and I I figure that would probably
put us in a sweet spot but that's just
one man's
opinion that's okay um he well he he's
saying so the Acer number on on line
three is
46.7 uh and he's saying he's comfortable
with that number but that number I'll
point out is higher than than uh
everything except the high of FY
27er representative YY
yeah I I understand what AC yeah well
yes they Chang the name and we don't
change it yeah the
uh spiking revenue from uh this uh from
utilities property tax took place when
uh the the major companies decided that
they were going to upgrade their um
cable sizes from X kilow to x squ
kilow uh you saw all the B building that
was taking place off the highways and
you know wood going down on the wetlands
as they went out and worked on the
towers and all that stuff
um that's almost all done but almost not
quite done so there's going to be some
growth yes but it's going to be less
growth than has taken place in the past
cers is a past react is a reactive
number as opposed to a proactive number
in we're trying to find proactive
numbers which is virtually impossible
but uh we get pretty close I think that
needs to be considered as well there may
be depending upon legislation passed a a
growth in the property tax offset by
swep taxes uh if we take the uh if the
Science and Technology bill passes out
uh but that's something we can't really
consider yeah representative Brier
I don't know I'm I'm looking at these
and uh I think we just take the
average sorry I I think we should just
take the average between the two numbers
represent of Southworth um I come up
with
459 for
2026 uh no we're um okay I came up with
464 the average oh I'm sorry I'm ahead
I'm at 2026 I already we haven't
confirmed Med
2025 but U is it was that an average
representative forth okay uh
representative elme thank you I'm sorry
did you have a followup well no my only
comment is you got a high and a low and
we really you know to be conservative I
just take the average between the two
okay thank you uh I'm sorry
representative you're too close I I
don't notice Abol be anyway yeah I just
want to point out there's an ongoing
program to hard of the infrastructure in
the in the United States all these large
poles that you see being replaced that's
going to continue as a matter of public
policy to harden the
infrastructure represent elme thank you
um if I remember correctly and the Dr
needs to tell me uh we they go out and
they evaluate also in in
April the
assessment
Bureau or do they do it year
round representative Al I'm not sure
about the April but we do assess these
properties um Dr does the assessments
for these properties I couldn't hear
most of that I'm sorry I said I'm not
sure about the April but we do Dr does
the assessments for these properties you
vary it yes between different months I
I'm not certain the timing of the yeah
of the appraisals but it they are done
by Dr on a regular basis yeah well what
I'm getting at is if they take as we do
for property taxes an April assessment
number uh and we've had a fair amount of
inflation since then in in a lot of
things on are we looking at the in the
low estimate as lower than what it would
actually be this year or so the the low
estimate uses the first seven months of
actual revenue and then adds plan to it
so I don't think that the uh impact that
you're looking for would necessarily be
in these estimated numbers
ah okay so it would be pretty much up to
date for 25 correct yeah okay okay
um all right so on um so on 2025 it
sounds like the the rough consensus here
is to go with an average which would be
what was it
45.2
yes
anyone okay all right FY 26 I know uh
Representatives oh wait a minute let
me
uh what what okay I'm wait until I call
on you because uh we we need organized
chaos here um all right representative
Southworth you had I had
459 459 which was an average and then
the next one is
466 the last one which is also an
average all right so you're an advocate
of average um of taking the average not
advocate of average and then what
okay uh representative um Ford did you
have something you wanted to say you
agree with the the average okay uh
represent elme no oh sorry all right so
in general people are saying okay let's
just go the average for 40 for 26 as
well and I would assume 27 same thing
average anyone have a huge problem with
that doesn't seem like it all right so
what are those numbers again the average
on 26 is what
459 okay and the average on 27 47
66 does anyone else confirm that so we
make sure okay yeah it was in my grace
house he's he's an educator he knows
what he's oh I know he knows what he's
doing I just want to make sure we don't
you know make a
mistake um okay would someone like to
make a motion to accept these numbers
could you give us the numbers again
please Mr chairman we're talking on uh
page six column
o line 11 45 thou um well not 45 5,000
for
uh these are millions so it's it's
45.2 million U line 16 is
45.9
million and line 21 is 46.6
million okay uh representative attorney
makes a motion to accept those numbers
do I have a second second second all
right representative Murphy
any further discussion seeing none all
in favor please raise your hand of these
numbers okay any opposed okay that's
unanimous and I believe we now have 16
people
here 13 14 15 oh wa I just counted 17
wait what is it oh he showed
up no wait one two three
17 okay thank
you all right so that concludes utility
property
tax all right
now okay so we are done with page 6
through 10 let's see what we have on
page
five page five uh let's go to uh real
estate transfer tax column
H thoughts on column H representative
Southworth thank you um I was able to
listen to the streaming for um r
presentation okay and it almost exactly
mirrored um our Register of Deeds
presentation that I just heard from
straford County okay so I know um she
they did contact the counties of course
to develop this but it was almost word
for word what our Register of Deeds said
okay again for what you can estimate
okay and therefore your conclusion so
that made me confident of in these R
numbers and again I would maintain that
it's wise with that having more
knowledge in a way than us to go with
the middle to go with the average okay I
am pleased that it's bouncing
back yes or projected to
yeah it it is you're right it is
bouncing back a little bit yes uh other
thoughts
representative
Aly
um yeah I I think I agree with that it's
bouncing back way too slowly for what we
need but but that seems given all of the
difficulty it's going to be even worse
difficulty of getting Timber and and
other inputs they're going to keep going
up in price so this is probably where we
are yeah well the beauty of this is we
don't know what um what's going to
happen um the timber may go up but it
may it may reverse itself too depending
on how policies change over the course
of time as
well okay uh did I see someone else
representative ORS so uh thank you Mr
chairman I agree with the idea of going
with the averages for 25 and 26 but 27 I
think we ought to be closer to the high
number I believe that we're going to see
fuel prices come down interest rates
come down
and we are going to we're going to see
the Golden Age of America in a short
period of time and I I think that these
numbers are going to really
rebound um representative Ying oh to
representing War's Point
yes
maybe we're in the process of setting
some general goals I I'm confident that
what will um what you suggest uh there's
a strong possibility probability that
will take effect but I think we need to
look at where we are now and get a
better sense as to what is happening for
the short term we're only dealing with a
twoyear budget and we're giving some
approximations out there
um we've got a lot of housing laws
that are coming
through some of those are
bipartisan some of them aren't on the
national scale the prime rate is subject
to a lot
of messing right now it could be up it
could be down who knows there's when
you're engaged in arguing with people in
negotiations sometimes it becomes you
got to just say okay what's this and not
worry about
that looking forward I would I would
think we need to probably be a little
more
uh cautious at this
point well I
I I think one of the one of the most
important things that uh Rees of Y just
said that I resonated with me as the
difference between two years and four
years like we can believe believe that
you know in four years everyone has a
belief on what will be the result in
four years but in two years probably
again not that much is changing and
there's a lot of challenges because even
if lumber prices come down let's say the
tariffs work in a way that actually
brings lumber prices down through
because through policy changes that are
affected by that the issue still is
there's a lot of people that are in
housing that they got into at three and
four per. and those people aren't
necessarily going to
uh sell their house and go into some if
the interest rates are still 6% or
higher not going to make the move and so
um it's still makes the housing market
difficult um
so yeah so factors from from
availability of lumber to interest rates
to people willing to put their homes on
there's so many variables that I would
say um I personally think the average is
probably where we want to be right now
but other thoughts representative
yeah to follow up on your point I think
the biggest Factor on all these various
unknowns is the interest rate factor and
that's primarily driven by the federal
budget unfortunately we don't have
regular order in the federal budget it's
all continuing resolutions so I don't
expect any budget to come out of
Washington which would mean it's up to
the Federal Reserve to determine
interest rates and that depends on the
money supply as represented all likes to
talk about
M2 so my guess is that in the forecast
that I read is that I don't see any big
changes in the federal deficit which is
still running about two trillion and
consequent they hav don't see any big
change in interest rates coming over the
next two years so I would assume things
would be relatively stable and not a big
increase until
2026 maybe
27 other
thoughts oh
yes uh right now there's a bill and I
know it's future but there's a bill for
us to tax carbon in the
trees if that passes that will we will
be the first state that will be taxing
carbon in the
trees uh when Foresters don't cut if it
doesn't pass lumber prices aren't coming
down because those properties are locked
up in the case of the one up north until
the year 213
they're not going to be harvesting much
Lumber out of there at all if any yeah
it's um I it's probably unlikely
something like that would pass I I think
last year there was a bill similar with
carbon
uh I don't I haven't studied that bill I
don't know how similar it is but I think
the odds of it passing are slim um and
and to your point we do need to stick
with what what is the current law right
now as we make these estimates any other
thoughts okay so is the consensus go
with the averages anyone violently
against that
idea okay so then let's go with the
averages uh real estate uh transfer line
11 what's the average of that has anyone
calculated
that 199
point4 okay fy2
6 to
10.7 and FY
27 okay so so we have our numbers now FY
[Music]
199.00
point7 27
rep representative Brier makes a motion
seconded by representative
Aly any last minute
thoughts seeing none all in favor of
those estimates please raise your
hand anyone
opposed no opposed so again that's I
don't think anyone left to came in so 17
to
zero okay
okay the only page that has items that
we have not voted on or is Page four
now what that
yeah all right so page four let's start
with um column
G Communications tax
uh thoughts on uh the communications tax
is one that is fairly
U stable it has uh decreased a little
bit in the in the past uh year or two
um and the agency looks like they're
keeping the high at 30 where it had
traditionally been but they are seeing
degradation in that and that's why you
see the low on 25 26 27 the low is
continually going down because uh I
think as they described there's more and
more uh data being um going through
um what was it cell phones texting um
and away from landlines is data yeah um
okay so thoughts representative
Southworth I'm sorry representative
Bolton had his light on first
um I think I would stay um more closely
to the lower
number yeah representative Southworth
I'm still uh fine with the averages
because it's barely difference actually
than until I mean barely gaps here yeah
representative
uh thought someone over here had
a
okay so uh so we had two people speak
one said go with the low one said
average so I need more
thoughts representative elme a average
representative
yery representative
average okay my question would be those
who want the
average uh we see a degradation year
after year so why would we um go with
the average that's my question the
average since the lower number is going
down the average is going to go down
also
ditto okay the a I just looked at the
AER number the AER is 30.5 which is
actually above the high so uh gives us a
safety the average might make sense uh
representative Y no that's I was just
going to point that out
okay all right yeah representative home
yeah I'm kind of leaning toward the low
side I see that because if you look at
the landline companies they're all
taking away the copper that's going to
be a VIP even though it's still going to
be from a landline company I just see
the
infrastructure of this
uh traditional landline tax uh declining
fairly sharply I believe so I'm declin
to go with the low numbers with the data
moving to other
methods well I I ordinarily would have
agreed with that until I looked at the
Acer number again and that that being
30.
uh6 which is above the 30 but I I don't
discount what you're saying either it's
it's a again we don't have we don't have
a crystal ball it's we're trying to do
our best uh to figure this
out all right is given
that um I'm fine with making a motion
just make see how it so you make a
motion to put your
microphone I make a motion to use the
averages for the communications tax do I
have a
second elme seconds it
okay any further
discussion anyone thinks the average is
an issue represent Al me a isue on the
first microphone please average is an
issue on the first one I suggest that we
we adjust down when it's
0.5 that is 20
[Music]
29.5 uh rather than
29.6 I see what you're saying okay
all right that's a slight change do you
want to rephrase your motion to round
down on the average on fy2 so I make a
motion to use the average and round down
um if it's 0.5 which goes along with
these people okay nice compromise okay
so line 11 would be
29.5 correct uh
line 16 is 29.1 yes
and line 21 is what's the average of
that that makes sense
okay all right further discussion on
that seeing none all in favor of those
numbers for the Communication Service
tax raise your
hand anyone
opposed
okay yes and just as a reminder to the
members this these numbers are subject
to modification when we feel like
it well up until I mean just to clarify
that
statement uh there up until the time
that we actually have a resolution which
will include all these numbers uh we
will vote on the resolution once we vote
on that that's the resolution now
representative ery might also be
alluding to the fact that um after the
resolution is brought before the house
and voted on if we see something really
changing drastically we can uh pull that
resolution off the T and by the way the
process is to table that resolution we
would then pull it off the table uh
modify it with an amendment if
it's uh this year I believe uh then we
can modify with an amendment put it back
on the table uh if it's next year that
we see something changing drastically we
have a new resolution with those numbers
and that gets put on the table um
represent El me yes and and after that
first one that first one goes into the
budget it's in stone but on after that
uh modifying the amendment or putting in
a new one on is a signal to the
legislature and the and the executive
that things have changed enough that we
need to think about modifying but it is
just a signal yeah yeah thank
you okay with that uh correct me if I'm
anyone thinks I'm wrong but I believe
the
only I'm saying only but the most
difficult are coming The Columns we have
left are column a b c and
e e might well e might be yeah E is easy
but I'm my point is we have a b c and e
left um okay what go to the uh
last well tobacco might not be too bad
but the last easy one interest and
dividends column
e um we obviously know that interest in
dividends is going away and that's why
we see a a rapid decline there
um and
2025 we still will see money coming in
from the 2024 tax returns and that's why
that number is still fairly
High okay thoughts on interest in
dividend and what we believe the number
should be representative Southworth is
quick on the button um full disclosure I
just paid
$13 $13 for indd indd I just I just
mailed
it anyway um I think we should accept
their um
numbers that's getting I wanted a couple
left okay so right but there's no
average here by accepting their numbers
well I guess you could still say it's
the average the average is 134.5 and
8.7 um anyone anyone else feel that
there's some some other number that
should happen here I mean I think as far
as this in my mind Dr is the one
analyzing this I don't think we have
information above and beyond what they
have cash flow yeah so Mr chairman yes
uh I'll agree with their numbers but I
do not like the policy that we're going
through
okay on this issue understood current
law um is all we're dealing
with but it's good to know your opinion
to representative
shamber okay um so would someone like to
make a motion to accept these
numbers representative uh Aly seconded
by representative
ORS
ORS you oh yeah
that
sound El me yeah
um um so the the motion is to accept
these numbers in column e as presented
by Dr all in favor please raise your
hand all
opposed uh seeing none the vote is uh no
one left right still
170 okay
all right we now have three left to do
column A B and C business taxes meals
and rooms and
tobacco and um I think we'll continue
working
uh from the uh right to left so column C
is
next uh tobacco thoughts on the tobacco
tax revenue
representative salw worth again I'm glad
to make a motion to use the averages I
think they've been studying this a long
time and watching the trends and I think
it's very reasonable
from
Cy however using the averages in the
last term resulted in
25 to the
negative maybe closer to the lower end
may be appropriate um the health
education in high schools seems to be
going strong although I that may be
countered by the stupidity of adding
taxes that our Southern neighbor is
doing so
so
maybe just under the averages closer to
the low side
because of the competing effects of
increased sales from out of state but
increased reduction in smoking because
it's becoming less socially
acceptable uh even to older folks but
representative uh Southworth would um it
work for you to take 0 five off the
average yeah thank
you people with calculators we can take
0 five off the average representative
home yeah support taking it down a bit
where I live at in N you go across the
border of tsoro and there's the weed
shops that are just packed with license
plates so I just see the trend from The
Smokers to go to an alternate product
represent
viy why would you put license plates in
a weed
shop any other any other uh useful
[Laughter]
comments okay uh so I just point out
that I go to too at a restaurant down
there to save the room and meal
Stacks saying meals and rooms okay
so someone with a calculator can you
please take the average and subtract
0.5 get
183.0 five and if we're taking five off
I guess it would be 183
18 yeah yeah so it's
18395 is the exact average so if you
take 0. five off
having rounded up to 184 it' be
183.2 or 18 okay
yes or if you take the 0. five off first
you simply add 1.1 to the low number and
that'll make it
1837 what how you got higher that that
brought it
higher the difference between the two is
2.7 if you take the 05 off first you're
down to 2.2 and then that's an easy
number to divide in half 1.1
Bingo does it work if you're standing on
your left leg yes it
does all I don't know I'm sticking with
the traditional add the two numbers
together and divide by
two I kind of like that idea I'm kind of
an oldfashioned guy
I do too but if they're giving but I was
an English major so you
know P Mass doesn't apply
here usually try not to do
ma
um I like one I like 183.0
representative El me yes I would just
suggest if we're trying to go lower that
whichever of those two numbers is lower
yeah the number which would be
183.0
yes okay I see a lot of n rep Tyne is
rep tyrany an accountant or math
major we can we can take that up later
no I thought so you're killing me okay
uh FY
26 um the what where what do those
numbers come out averaging minus .5 did
somebody calculate
that 176
176.000 after you deduct the half yeah
right okay
and the last one oh did you have a
comment on yeah
um we're not supposed to consider
pending legislation but maybe that
number should be just a couple higher
because of pending legislation in
Massachusetts we no no there's no
guarantee that that'll come through uh
and the last one what's the average
there I gave
174 oh I didn't take off the half point
so
1735 1735 confirm and representative
Ford is giving me the high sign so okay
and I trust representative Ford
implicitly on good good to know good to
know okay so she's an educated you can
trust
her so to sum up we took the average of
each of those and we subtracted 0 five
and we got for line 11 on the tobacco um
tax we got
183.2 line 16 we got
176.000 and on line 21 we got
173.50 any further
discussion all right actually would
someone like to make a motion on
this don't be shy representative
tney do I have a
second
represent seeing no further discussion
um oh did you want to say something else
no that's good all right your light is
sorry left
over um all in favor please raise your
hand of those numbers
okay all opposed seeing none that's
170 okay we have two left uh we'll now
go
to meals and rooms column B represent J
and for the meals and rooms I would
suggest that you go to the um first page
where the Dr ranges are so you can use
the gross number okay on line seven when
you're doing your
estimates because once you get that
number um we'll have to do a calculation
to back out the municipal transfer in
the um School building right all right
so if you look at page
three column
s we have the high and low for 25
through 27
do we have
a I have a comment so we don't have an
act for number then on on that do
we the the act for number would have
backed out um the transfers because
they're not in the general fund okay
right so it's just so what yeah what I
meant is we don't have a gross you don't
have a gross number um yeah for plan
essentially but you could
um is it I think it's
131 for this
year
yeah I mean we could back into it once
we grab that number um
okay representative Southworth a quick
question so the top should say 25 26 27
correct yeah and I think I'm changing my
mind because it usually does better than
we expect I was thinking of taking the
average and then adding a little bit to
it like 0.2 or something like that um
because for years it's come in better
than we expected and at least in the Sea
Coast Area people go out no matter what
else is
happening I don't know at first I was
going to say add 0.5 but I think that's
too much I just maybe add point2
yeah that's why I'd like to see what the
the gross number was to see how yeah I
know you thank you um because once we
have that we can see these might already
be taking that
exra
for e
General General thoughts while we're
waiting for the
numbers that's for 25
yes okay and this is for fiscal year 25
which as I walked over completely forgot
the number I
quoted 4
63.2 yes representative
Smith uh while we're waiting de mind if
I ask a question well she's got the
number now uh 4
63.2 is the gross plan for fiscal year
25 okay thank you um now did you have a
question representative Smith 463 yes I
did thank you uh excuse me Mr
Shay I'm sorry Mr Shay yes I was curious
um do you know were these estimates put
together using say a linear regression
model or were they done say with a Time
series model or an ARA that would
be so for um the for the M&R um well I
do I look at the Historical trends for
each component of the tax to get a
Baseline and then compare that to how
the tax is doing to get to that range so
it is more of a Time ser Tech all right
thank you you're
welcome and just uh for fiscal year 24
the gross number would be
4647 it's not the AC for number that
would have been the plan
number so you to the Acra number if you
had um 37.3
say that say that again what what number
did you come up with so it' be four 467
would have been with the a for number
plus what was removed for the municipal
and school building a it's approximately
467 all right
all right so knowing
that so if we look if we look at that
um so are we I'm a little confused
463.3339
67 would be fiscal year
24 using the AC for number and making
the adjustment for the um Municipal a
municipal fund and school building Aid
transfer so that that seems a little
surprising so from 24 is higher than
25 it when we said that rooms I thought
so some of that has to do with the the
municipal transfer that's why you have
to do the gross estimate and then we
have to back up out the transfer because
the calculation involves looking at last
year's
Revenue coming up with a transfer number
that you appli to the year you're going
to go to so you take 25's Revenue get
figure out the municipal Revenue that
should be transferred you make the
transfer in 26 so your your estimated
number may look a little lower or higher
based on the municipal transfer and the
school building Aid
transfer okay and also um our high and
low for fiscal year 25 is a of the plan
number that we are recommending so that
463.3339
and they continue to go higher each each
year so do you still feel like it should
be above the average that was my thought
but I'm very comfortable with the
average yeah and it seems like they the
trend I was seeing they were seeing also
so seems like that is built in pretty
well yeah it seems like it's built in I
just threw it out but I think the
average is fine
yeah other
thoughts average higher than average
lower than average I like the average
okay
represent yeah I was picking up
conflicting Trends on some of the stuff
I'm looking at one is that there was a
trend after Co for people to get out of
the house start to enjoy life again the
other trend is now expenses are cing up
credit card debt is increasing so it
seems to be flattening out with those
two Trends so I'm kind to go with the
average you a thought
okay what uh what are the
averages we're on column column B the
averages are the numbers that's halfway
between it's also called the median h no
it's not no the median is
different
Med
correct you mean medium mean yeah
average and mean are the
same I'm wondering uh
what okay yeah the growth rate from the
to
475 to
um well let's see you would take
so to answer your question uh for the
low that is a
1.7% growth on the gross and on the high
that's a
2.6% growth on the gross
okay and is that true each year
that the range is then two to 5% growth
okay um so wait a minute just to be
clear so fy2 is 1.7 on the low side and
2.6 on the high side and then the
following gear are two on the low side
and 5% on the high side correct okay and
that fiscal year 25 is on the um the AC
for number not the cash number
okay
okay um all right so anyone not
comfortable with the
averages okay what are the averages then
so let's look at uh page four column
B so it's the average of repres you're
going to want to use the averages on
page three so you're going to want to
use a gross number and do your averages
off from that average on page three oh
because we're presenting the gross
number you're gonna you're G to mention
a gross number and then either go to
business taxes and once you've done that
I'll take a second and figure out what
the meals and rooms will be or you can
take a break and we can figure out meals
and rooms and you can move the business
taxes but it'll take us five or 10
minutes just to run the number get the
actual number yeah okay so Mr chairman I
I've calculated the gross averages so
for for fiscal 25 it would be
4771 and representative Ford gives me
the can you talk in your microphone oh
sorry 4 77.1 for fiscal
4939 for fiscal
26 and
51.3 for fiscal 2
7 and I even got a thumbs up from
representative tney that
time all right um representative Aly
thank you
uh the cafer that we just calculated for
this year from last year is
only somewhere between 1.7
2.5% growth
from FY 24 that's a lot lower than where
where we've been
growing and I'm
wondering at going to an average which
is considerably higher than that for
growth in the next
term that's a really good question so
what we are really seeing and I think
it's some of the conversation that we're
talking about at what point have we hit
the top of the impact on the
inflationary cost on meals and people's
ability to go out to eat in that shift
so what we had seen was very large
growth coming out of the pandemic with
that um what they've termed Revenge
travel and I think we've just kind of
just hit that bit but we still think but
I am still noticing that there is growth
um occurring and that the weather has
been favorable and that there are people
that are still going out and um in some
months I'm seeing Hotel seeing a shift
upwards we had lost a couple of
properties that are now coming back
online and so we're seeing some of that
too but all the way up to
8% oh wait I'm sorry are we on meals and
rooms or we moved on to business rooms
okay five oh sorry sorry I was looking
at the business
TX
um and I think to just piggyback on what
Lauren said it's yeah it's also the 2 to
5% range historically has been the trend
for meals and rooms preo so I think um
what Dr might be seeing is that we're
starting to get back into that that
normaly that we had before Co
struck yeah we were for a long time
going up 5% a
year other okay other thoughts comments
is the average the right place to be
okay ready for a motion represent of
Southworth um I make the motion for
meals and rooms for um to accept the
averages for
4771 for
2026 4
93.9 and for 2027
511 um representative Aly did not hear
what you said yeah it well it's it's
hard to find a place on this chart to
put this stuff I just wrote it right
under the number in that little space
under the tun WR it under the dollar
sign right
yeah so the second one
4771 yeah for what
493 oh I got totally
wrong 4 93.9
and
okay so um representative Southworth
just um made a motion to accept the
averages and he just said what those
averages were do I have a second second
by representative tney
further discussion seeing none all in
favor please raise your
hand anyone
opposed none okay so and I think we lost
uh what one person or is it still
17 l two so 15 Mary had had to go to
right right 15 Z okay so we'll let uh
while they're calculating while um
they're calculating the actual number uh
we can move on and discuss business
taxes and um we've moved along very
nicely to this point we have one one
item left and that's business taxes uh
yeah given that uh we we still have
U this afternoon to work on this as well
and we we do have an exec session
starting at two but let's see what we
can do I mean if we can come to
agreement on business taxes then we
effectively would finish our Revenue
estimates today and then it could be put
into a
resolution um for a vote probably on on
another day but uh yes represent elme
thank you I know I said I was going to
print out the the major end of month
chart and I really feel
uncomfortable
on finishing this one before looking at
it uh but I had so much I had to do when
I got home last night that I couldn't do
that well can we um can we get it so
what are you asking for end of month end
of the end of month for January chart
that shows the the refunds
the
um
uh um it it's a it's a large it shows it
shows all the all the taxes plus the
refunds plus the refunds and a number of
other things um what is that chart
called sure so um for the business taxes
that is um the name if you were to find
it in your email it is called the legal
size business tax tax analysis yeah and
then it will say like fiscal year 2025
and then whatever month you want to look
at so the most current is what we call
January
final
right okay is there any way that uh we
can get that printed out and get it for
one one o'clock continuation absolutely
okay oh
good yeah it's only it's a two-sided
legal
and I really want to see what's
happening to the refunds I
mean can we get it sooner than one or is
I don't know what your process
is once
so if you wanted to take a a short
recess I can run back and print
it um and then in that time frame we can
tie up these Municipal numbers as well
well you have lunch
is there anything well can we talk about
this without having those right
now yeah um yeah bring them for for one
o'clock yeah I don't want to you know
because we're gonna get we're GNA get
tight but um so one o'clock we'll have
those numbers maybe maybe if all goes
well we can finish up uh today let me
just ask this uh Chris if we if we vote
and finish this today um can you
um well no you have to create a
resolution correct
orh and then have to
so if your intention was to get your
numbers done today to finish your
numbers today um I think you you have
executive session starting at 2 o'clock
yeah so once you were done with me I'd
go back I finish the splits come back
with a final spreadsheet that you guys
would say yep that's what we want to see
and based on those numbers which show
you the education trust fund and the
general fund splits I would then create
the resolution for you I think you're
here tomorrow for exec sessions or Bill
work anyways uh I think exec session is
ex exec session mentioned on the I think
it is exact could be done think we could
but we don't have anything listen
hearing tomor no I know we have he uh
oh
um yeah we're hearings but we also
mention exact or we or we push but there
a lot of
hearings there a fair number of hearings
in there 3 in the morning 1 in the
afternoon that's two one of them got
removed so all I was going to suggest is
I could
potentially try to get a resolution
together for the end of your work
tomorrow bring it to the committee so
you could look at it and give a yay or a
nay to it or sit on it for a period of
time to you know think about it I but I
can talk with the chair at the break and
see how you want to proceed with it in
terms of time of what your committee
work is I mean I guess I just realized
too the I need to get the schedule in
for next week by 12:00 tomorrow so we
probably won't have we won't know so
what I'll do is I'll probably say that
we're having a
um oh um not sure how to phrase it work
session or exec session on the
um estimated numbers or on the
resolution I don't think I have to be
that specific I I think could just
notice it as a work session on the on
the numbers and then um the committee
would just do a final nod to the
resolution yeah in case there's some
other information that comes to the
committee's attention that you want to
make adjustments you still have the
opportunity to do that right yeah so
I'll I'll probably do that the 19th will
probably be that day to vote on this the
other piece too is that the following
week is the I think isn't that the
vacation
week so you wouldn't have a session that
week anyways for the resolution to go to
it would be the probably the first if
you have a session day in March it would
the first week of sorry the first week
of March would probably be the soonest
that you would get the resolution before
the full body no and that's fine I I
would probably get it done uh next
Wednesday the
19th and it can be handed over to
finance before anybody else sees it yeah
yeah that's yeah give finance an
opportunity to jumping up and down okay
so if that's the case and my my effort
would be to get you a worksheet for
tomorrow um by the end of today maybe
but maybe first thing tomorrow so I can
make sure I don't forget fiscal year
numbers or anything like that yes we
could just take a look at it then uh you
could uh put together the uh
resolution okay
um so that being said uh we'll get that
uh
calculation uh on the actual numbers for
meals and rooms and
um we'll also get the spreadsheet for
one for one o'clock when we come back so
in the meantime it's only 11:20 Let's uh
let's just discuss business taxes in
general um we will get further backup
information um at one o'cl when we look
at the January
numbers so who would like to go first
with their thoughts on business tax
representative Southworth it might as
well be you
um again I would just for a starting
point um look at the averages and my own
opinion for analogy is just picture a
dart board I mean I'm just thinking yeah
yeah
right a little too much
transparency yeah we're we're we're
supposed to be deliberative you know
they use many factors to do this and I
just think uh um you know it's there a
lot of things we could throw in and
we'll still come close to the average so
I would just put that out if someone
really has a crystal ball I haven't
heard of it
yet okay represent
elme oh sorry Oh I thought you had
something prophetic to
say uh representative ORS you look like
you want to say
something
okay so we're we're not going to vote on
this right now but I mean do people feel
comfortable the averages do have
others uh yeses El
okay yeah I had one note on here
from somebody said that the low
employment rate was good for the
economy and I don't quite understand how
that works the low who said that uh I
can't I one of us oh someone in the
committee said that yeah oh okay yeah
not not the people from Dr or LBA the
low unemployment rate is that you said
yeah okay but it's a drag on our economy
wow
and she may yeah represent yes represent
you I yes and no it's a drag on the
economy in that it increases the wages
of uh employees
which affects the profitability of each
individual Corporation but it's a boom
to the uh GDP because it indicates that
we're approaching a capacity uh of
production which
then generates more Revenue
but in general
it's a disincentive for businesses to
locate here so you you got two minuses
and a
plus repres well it's a disincentive to
businesses to stay here
also uh when you can't get enough people
to run uh run your
business uh no matter what you're you
can afford to pay them that that what's
that's what I I mean in general the
unemployment rate my understanding is is
low across the country so it's it's it's
something that um a lot of states have
that chall represent and I would I would
counter that argument a bit if you've
got low unemployment then you got
incentive to do investment in tools that
make your Workforce more productive and
I think that would be an economic
stimulus well okay
representative
Yi New Hampshire has becoming high-tech
uh Hub um there was the article in
business uh New Hampshire uh regarding
in the Army program that we worked on uh
which seems to um although we haven't
received a formal uh analysis of it the
uh they've never given it to us I think
we asked once yeah we ask again this
year the U that seems to be generating
good propaganda for them that indicates
that New Hampshire may be benefiting
substantially from the uh uh Army
process but at the same time um
depending upon world events
uh nashille and south Hudson uh and
miramac will'll see uh some growth um
Hyperion should uh see some massive
growth but you still have to hyperon
excuse me uh need to have um somebody's
got to put the wrench to the screw
eventually and so
Rob yeah well they can do that but
depends on what they're doing so
representative is um m is correct that
there would be an
increased
um Proficiency in doing a single job
where we're a high-tech area we may get
robots we may even get the robots to
move from rout three South to rout three
North
but it it depends on the cost of
electricity and everything else so it's
it's where where did is that Dart Bird
Go D dartboard I know all right any and
some are better shots than others so
have having heard uh represent Yul and
okay representative Aly yes uh I just
and
Lebanon has now that you said hyperon I
can't remember the name Har
hypothermal Nordisk uh for for the
United States and it's got a lot of
medium level ones that you haven't heard
of but are very important in the economy
and they all are suffering from not
enough
workers and they all are suffering
because and the hospital uh they they
have 800 vacancies at at uh the largest
hospital in New Hampshire uh and they
they
um they cannot get Workers because the
workers come wanting to work there and
then look for housing and then go
away
so
um I think I I see it
as as a real problem in in our future
growth
uh because we're not going to be able to
solve the housing market sufficiently to
help with this probably for years to
come okay so uh representative ul and
representative Aly you've talked about
this I want to hear each of you so
representa Aly where do you think where
are you comfortable with these
numbers it's been suggested that we
average them
and I realize we're you know we're going
to come back with get some more
information when we come back from lunch
but just for now while this is all you
have to look
at the
low St well no comes up it comes up a
little bit in 26 and up in
um which is probably
true well microphone represent Omie
sorry I I think it will be be growing
some from there how much of it will be
inflation I'm not sure yeah
but we've got to do something about the
housing and the something costs a lot of
money and we've got too many other
things that we have to pay
for uh okay well so I I understand your
concerns what I'm saying is where so
where do you think where do you yeah
feel like you're coming
in I would
be would be closer to the
lowend on
25 then the
highend
and
say say about um
one one
1.4 billion we're talking a billion
there um no that doesn't make sense 1.4
billion sorry no no no no not that one
1.04 so I guess that would be 1.04 okay
so instead of 1.06 or so you're at 1.04
but all right after that I mean it's so
hard to estimate whether we're going to
be able to most most people can't but
that's why we're the ways and means
we're able to estimate estimate well I'd
like to see the refunds also okay I
understand representative
YY what do you feel like
I see the first
quarter 25 being a little low and I see
a steady growth going forward from there
barring penal blowing up or something
like that
but I'll stick with the agency
low um and then maybe maybe reduce the
for 26 and then for
um maybe a little bit better just round
that right up to
1.1 so what about
1.1 black growth for the next two years
well 1.1 you're you're above the average
then for 25 that doesn't make sense
no well above the well yeah the average
is fine yeah the average is 0.0
1.0 I don't know yeah
six 1.01 1.05 yeah somewhere in
there representative you said did you
something no sorry I'm gesturing and
thinking out
loud I don't think there's any uh Silver
Bullet uh with the 25 estimates so i'
I'd stay on the lowest side of of things
too so or 25 yeah and then 26 and 27
same thing I agree with Jordan yeah
yeah
it's
uh representative elme and then yeah I'd
just like to point out if we're being
consistent well I'm sorry you you
finished yeah go ahead we're we're
rounding
to
100,000 point something so when we're
looking at a billion
two we're we're we should be rounding to
a billion
2.5 or something like
that rather than to a billion
02 and I just took that number out which
is a high estimate and I don't believe
in representative I was just going to
make kind of a blanket suggestion on the
conservative side of things I again
would stay with the lower estimate the
agency low low for 25 but allow for
maybe a
2.5% incremental
increase on both both year is I think
it's uh still within reason and it's
still very conservative I think there's
a lot of factors we could all sit here
and and talk about that that come into
come into play and again the crystal
ball effect isn't you know that in two
bucks will get you a bowl of soup I
think we're better off on the
conservative side yeah yeah I I think
the I I agree with that I think the
conservative side on 2025 especially
because no matter
um how good or bad you think um you know
the coming years are going to be even if
you think they're going to be good um
we're not we're just starting uh
nothing's going to change that fast and
and and for 2025 we're talking about
five more months so I I agree in the
sense that probably the low end of 2025
makes sense because um
yeah because not not a whole lot's going
to be changing and then we can talk
about what we think the growth might be
for 2026 and 2027 but I think that makes
sense representative South Southworth
yeah I um put out the averages just to
get the discussion going but my personal
opinion is we should lean towards the
low end thank
you
representative I
I've that is one of the reasons why I
asked the drra the commissioner to give
us a historical analysis of the past of
how they've been on and off but looking
at the business tax revenues from 2015
to
2024 I believe that the last four years
have been sort of an anomaly because of
the economic stimulus that has been
thrown in there about
um uh the supply chain I I think we're
going to see a lot of different things
occurring most of the changes from 2015
to
2020 you were only looking as as
representative Aly said somewhere
between 150 200 million change up or
down as you go when we jump from 709
million to 1 billion 300,000 it it there
there's there this is an anomaly and I
think that even the low we're going is
too high
I really believe that I but I'd like to
see what the results of the
Dr will be I think that we can we're 15%
right now
below what we should be in
plan 15% it's un audited I understand
but it's still 15% below
so my feeling is that unless we're under
a billion I I just don't see us I
myself won't be able to to
support I may be the negative vote but
still go forward
mhm
okay I mean one thing that I've I've
noticed and and Dr can correct me if
this is wrong but it seems like the
amount that we've been under as we go to
each month isn't isn't changing that
much it's a fairly steady amount is it's
pretty much a similar amount isn't it
each month as we
just about so what really what we're
seeing here is the um the tail end of
the estimates for tax year 24 and then
and then we're going to start seeing the
tax year 25 um in this spring so it's
really one thing definitely need to
consider is that we have historically
high overpayments and we and at the end
of fiscal year 24 we did have continued
to have historically High
overpayments um in addition to the
refunds so so while we we can talk about
what the economy is doing is how is that
how is that cash going to
materialize and knowing that there are
these liabilities out there so we're
seeing those Returns come in with zero
cash associated with it either through
those overestimate o o overestimates and
those credit carryovers being
utilized as because they have two
choices you can use it or you can get it
refunded and and those are the two ways
that we're seeing that so I think that's
something that we need to consider
too okay thank you um so my point was
where we're seeing it we know the co
money is slowly going away but yet the
the monthlies while under aren't like
suddenly dropping faster um would uh
lead me
to be more comfortable with the low the
low number um but representative BS uh
thank you Mr chairman so I have a
question thanks for taking it are the
employment numbers in the state of New
Hampshire over the last 68 months are
they level are they up or are they
down I didn't see a whole lot change and
and from what I understand when I was
updating the presentation that we are
actually doing better than the United
States uh the state of New Hampshire in
terms of that unemployment rate in a
good way thank you so that would confirm
what I'm thinking which my crystal balls
know better than anybody else but I'm
thinking we ought to be on the low end a
little bit if you will for 2025 but I'm
very optimistic for 26 and
27 I believe we're going to solve this
housing problem through
legislation and if we don't shame on
us Aly yes uh the housing problem is
going to require the kind of money I
think if we were actually going to get
it done
fast on that on we are facing spending
on the
lawsuits for um the the CH the child
system
which and we do have some other law on
lawsuits that we don't know what's going
to happen with them so um
but
but it's going it we would have to be
paying really good
wages uh to the people who produce the
housing in order to get them to come
here rather than in Massachusetts or in
South Carolina a lot of our people that
that did this kind of thing moved to
South Carolina North Carolina
Florida uh because they couldn't get
jobs here we had two recessions housing
recessions uh one just before I came
came home and and the other one in the
Great Recession and people just that
kind of people just left because they
had good skills they were going to use
them places where it was easier to make
a
living thank you any other uh any other
thoughts I mean at this point um you
know we we will come back at one o'clock
and um have a little more data to look
at um and um unless someone else has
something i''d like to say right now I
think we'll we'll probably adjourn and
come back at
one okay okay all right we'll come back
at uh 1:00 thank
you
e
e e
okay the time being 101 we'll get back
to work on our final estimates on uh
business taxes so um Chris if you want
to just let us know what you just passed
out that would be a good start yep so
you got two long sheets that I just put
in front of everyone uh the first one is
the business tax analysis sheet it's a
two-sided 8 and half by 14 it has um I
thinkom had asked for the refund
information which is um um part of
what's in there you have returns you
have extensions so and it's a history
for the last 10 years I think is and so
um as many of you have noted uh the
print is kind of small it's because
there is a lot of information um I sent
an email yesterday with forwarding all
these documents to you so if you have a
computer you can pull it up or if you're
at home you can look at it there as well
the second long sheet was just uh refund
analysis for the business taxes as well
as the interest and dividends just so
it's a little bit larger print it's a
one-sided 8 and a half
by14 um again just trying to get
something that people can look at so you
can um use that as you need and then the
last document is an 8 and 1 12 by 11
with a little box at the top these are
the um M&R
estimates so if you look at it you 25 26
and 27 um the second um column is the
gross average that you came up with so
that's the 4771 the 4939 and the
51.3 from there um I worked with the and
we did a calculation to determine what
the municipal um transfer would be that
goes into that dedicated fund as well as
the school building Aid and that's the
number in the third column over the 1432
1454 and the
1501 you take that away and you come up
with the net revenue that will be what's
your estimate and that's um
333.7401 million in 26 and 361.50
million in fiscal year
27 so those are the three documents that
weren't at your dat table when you left
that are there now
represent El
me thank you if everybody has understood
the meals and rooms Revenue estimate I'd
move the revenues for meals and
rooms do I have a second second
okay you want to speak to
that yes um
basically it
looks it it I I believe this is from the
numbers that we gave you yes yes so it
it represents a little bit lower than
the middle uh except that it is
different because we are um using we are
having to take a different amount of
annual transfer out for the
municipalities each year and sometimes
it's above uh looks like it
was below this time for 25 so so the
each year as the Ms and re
uh M&R comes in higher the following
year you're going to see more taken out
to go into the municipal Revenue uh fund
right
so that does have an impact on the
amount left that would go to the general
fund so this is what we were talking
about in all three cases yeah and it and
it ends up being pretty close to the
average
yeah it does all right so I don't I
don't think there's any surprises here
um is
uh if there's no more discussion on that
then uh let's we'll just vote on these
updated numbers uh all in favor raise
your
hand
opposed no
okay 14 15 16 yeah we voted um if
there's if there's any confusion the
reason it seems like we voted on it
twice is the first time we voted on the
uh the Topline numbers the gross numbers
uh and now that we have the actual
numbers um as per
the sheet that we just went over um
that's why we just voted on those yes so
we confirmed math we confirmed our math
yeah okay so that brings us back to
business
taxes and um represent are you elme you
ready to speak on that I would like to
talk with the Dr
about the uh what I remembered was that
they said that the
refunds uh are dwindling away at this
point it looks like the refunds are
going to be as high as they were last
year well I I think what was mentioned
earlier with um by Lauren is that there
is going to continue to be some
adjustments in
25 shouldn't be maybe as much as in 24
but as we move further away from 25 you
should see less of that because again
the idea of the right sizing of the CCO
and your um your your business tax rate
reductions The Bu the businesses have
adjusted for those with their new
estimates um but yeah eventually we'll
get there but it doesn't look like we're
getting there in
25 well I think I mean they can correct
me if I'm wrong but if I look at the
refund um schedule I mean I it seems to
be less than than prior year um so I
mean I think you're seeing the trend of
coming down when you compare it to the
previous year's equal month it
it maybe well I think I think what's
What's Happening Here is that in 2024
when you see this big jump yeah the
reason for that is because people were
were asking for refunds thinking that it
was dropping to
250% from 500% on we then at the end um
uh no I'm sorry I'm in the wrong year
2023 is when
that started was when that started and
we and we changed it so at that point
people were in 2023 being informed that
it's going to go to 20
250% so they started making changes in
their in their uh ask for refunds but
then in was it in 2024 uh we changed
that to stay at 500% for the next five
years and so now you're probably seen
that behavior change and you're seeing a
drop 111 down to 94 so I think the big
jump up was because they were
anticipating this huge change and now we
are getting away from that well it's
85.4
million on half
year
so we're there oh there were
15 well there were 15 million that came
in in
January so it's it's pretty close to
what it was last year when we finish off
the year
probably so if you compare the um second
to last row that's your fiscal year um
to date so that would give you when
you're looking at the January number for
25 that gives you how much was collected
through um January 24 you can see it was
111 in change in 24 and it's 94 in
change in in
2025 so it's down slightly from in the
first seven months as it compared to
last year um it's not that it's gone
away you still have it it's higher than
previous the CCO and business tax
changes but I think what Dr has
presented is that um they expect this to
start to smooth out the companies have
made the adjustment not to carry as much
money going forward because they're
being told you can't have it here if
you're over 500% the Dr is going to give
it back to you in that process they've
also right-sized their estimates as it
relates to their business tax payments
estimates so the combination of the two
I think what has been suggested when you
get in the 26 and 27 you should see kind
of a you're going to still have refunds
no matter what but you're not going to
have as greater refunds as you've seen
in the last couple years until you get
to the next stepping stone with the
ccos and if I'm incorrect I asked drra
to jump up wave their hands and let you
know that I'm speaking out of turn yeah
you got a thumbs up so all right
perfect there was something else going
on there which was that and
uh uh commissioner steep agreed with me
when we were talking about this last
fall that there were was a
probability that the big firms that for
whom we are a DOT on a page uh uh were
not noticing that we had been cutting
their taxes for the last X years it's
been 8 10 years or whatever it is on and
were not noticing that they had left a
lot of money sitting on the table
and um corrected that we're correcting
that um so it's there there are two
things operating there and the question
is when does the well run dry a
bit when do they they finish taking
stuff
out and well I don't think it's going to
run dry for a while because we're it's
going to level off a little bit but
we're still at 500% and at some point
we're going to get close to 2029 and um
well yeah and we we're gonna have the
same issue potentially we may have the
same
issue but do we have anyone left with
more than
500% in the
treasury
just so representative Al each year um
taxpayers may find themselves again
above the 500% level because if they pay
more in uh again even after they've
received a refund that gets them down to
that cap um then if they pay additional
estimates in the subsequent year they
could again exceed the cap so there may
always be some uh forced refunds to get
people down to that 500% cap on what
they can carry forward but uh we have at
this point cleared out a lot of the
large um balances that were being
carried forward from older tax years um
in the last two years when we've been
applying the cap and I think the
conversation that you may have been um
thinking of from the commissioner last
fall was basically to that effect that
that we have now cleared out a lot of
the higher balances and that there is an
expectation that until the cap drops
again that that that may level off um
also um keeping in mind
that the other piece that she talked
about yesterday was that estimates um
having now um that there's a lag between
when the estimates are made and then
when the return is filed that taxpayers
have now learned um how our new system
works and maybe right sizing their
estimates so that that may also change
the trend going forward
this the treasury told us essentially
that that they were going to be going
down in the amount of Interest they were
paying but it didn't seem like it was
going down a
lot
and
the the other thing about this is that
people
um we could never figure out why people
were leaving this huge excess of money
in our treasury at first we thought it
was because the federal
taxation on on limit was too high that
uh on percentage that they taxed at the
highest levels of of income was too high
and then they did the tax cuts and jobs
acts and it didn't seem to make much of
any
difference
um just to clarify uh the money that the
businesses leave at Dr in in that credit
carrier over payments don't earn
interest so that does that's not
connected to what the treasurer was
talking about in terms of the interest
that she's dealing with uhhuh it's a
cash in cash out type of a system
there's a paper record of what companies
have paid what they might have overpaid
so when they true it up it's all done on
a paper and if we have to pay them back
it's t taken out of the cash that's
collected the month you're doing that
refund and that's why if you look at the
daily revenue reports you'll sometimes
see a fluctuation in the business tax
where you got a negative adjustment on a
particular day um the Dr typically has
done um a refund issue at that point and
that's what accounts for those um so
yeah I just want to make sure it's clear
that the the there's no interest earned
on those those dollars that that the
companies deposit with the state it's a
cash in cash out type of basis um so
that one is not related to this one
right right the the interest that the
treasurer was talking about is more
related to the cash on hand as it
relates to um arpa the infrastructure
act money um and then just having
healthy balances with our um uh rainy
day fund um you education trust fund has
a balance to it so you had a pool of
cash that she's able to invest and earn
some interest on in the next year and a
half you expect to see much of the arpa
to disappear um the trend we're seeing
with the education trust fund is that
balance is shrinking um so there may not
be as much money to invest to get
interest and that's why she's showing
you that by the end of 27 the trajectory
is down and we're going to probably get
closer to more of our normals um you
know the the the big fund that should
stay healthy I think is the rainy day
fund as long as nothing surprises Us in
the nor used to be that there was not
enough to invest that that's correct
that's absolutely
correct I still don't like the size of
these refunds
but but we were deciding
to
to go below the go below the
average yeah I think if we're if we're
on the low side of the average that may
help make up for some of this uh refund
concern and it may it may in fact Force
us to the low to the low estimate
um other thoughts
or questions if you have questions about
this sheet yes I just a question I guess
back to representative yery okay were
you're thinking that um we were aiming
towards um the low estimate on all of
these um
years yeah I would be a little more
optimistic for 27 but that's I was just
trying to clarify yeah okay I'd agree
with that
anybody anybody else have thoughts or or
or maybe questions about the sheets that
we have here everyone understand what's
here uh representative ORS uh thank you
Mr chairman so yeah I'm I'm looking at
the numbers and I'm thinking I agree in
2025 we don't want to go too
high um I'm thinking we ought to do
13 in
2025 I'm thinking we do 20 in 2026
1.12 and in
1.20 what was 26 again 25 I had I
have3
26120 271 1
yeah represent yeah thanks you talk
about the percent the percent increases
over that Baseline so I could get a
better reference I I did not do it on a
percentage basis I did it looking at the
refunds that we've been talking about
and the uh interest and
dividends and the way uh I've seen the
economy rolling uh watching the stock
market as I have recently when the news
is good the Market's greened when the
news has been bad the market turns and
the news is going to be good I mean this
is going to
be I think it's going to be amazing uh
period of time for the next couple
years and I can't imagine what the years
three and four will look like
but um you know when I looked at the
charts
recently the
the take-home effect which has a lot to
do with the
economy and wrong glasses sorry about
that and when I looked at the
charts it would look like that under
Trump with people having more money to
spend people having more money to spend
means more money on meals and rooms and
rentals and vacations and all
that the last four years with Biden look
like that that's the money that people
did not have to spend and so I believe
with President Trump the current
administration's agenda of
drilling
and what the things we're already seeing
the money that they're already showing
that's been misspent we're talking
Millions if if they break two trillion I
I would be shocked I don't think it'll
be that high but I think we're
definitely going to see uh they're going
to they're going to shake out over a
trillion dollars and we're going to see
this economy
boom energy drives the world we've
already learned that green energy is
failing these windmills they you know
people forget they run on oil they run
on diesel they need diesel engines to
start the blades are so big the these
wind turbines just don't turn on
themselves and we've seen where the wind
turbines are coming apart the Coatings
are coming off they're affecting our
beaches
uh green energy is not the way we go
we've already seen it in Europe Germany
is taking a beating and it's going to
continue and the way to go is clean
energy I agree clean it's but it's
called nuclear and if Google and AI are
buying places like and looking to buy
more threemile Island after all these
years I worked within 30 minutes of
Three Mile Island it didn't concern me
then it doesn't concern me now obviously
it doesn't concern them with the future
and energy the requirements that we are
going to need to move our economy
forward we are going nuclear whether
people like it or not and right now we
have the fossil fuels to move this
country forward until that stuff comes
online and I think we're going to see
this this is going to be the next four
years are going to be amazing I mean I'm
already starting to see I'm starting to
see it in the grocery stores a little
bit I'm seeing it at the pump as I
mentioned it the other day where I'm
buying my gas it's down 6 cents I looked
at my numbers for the last few years for
fuel oil and the trend was up and now
the trend is down and I'm excited for
the next four
years thank you representative
opal um I was just looking at a report
from The Joint economic committee issued
by
Congress and um the national average for
wages and salaries grew by nearly
$16,700 since
2021 outpacing price growth inflation by
that uh during that period by
$3,800 so just a a point of of you know
statistic that actually wages grew in
the last four years I don't know what
they're going to do in the next four
years maybe they'll grow maybe they
won't but at least in the last four
years we had to work on on facts yeah
wages are growing this is we're not I'm
not wait wait it's not a debate oh no
thought thought we're having a
discussion okay no it's a discussion but
I have to call I have representative I
have to call on I have to call on you
before you
respond now would you like to respond
representative thank you Mr chairman
sorry about that I was just trying to
have a discussion I agree with you the
Wes have gone up but prices have gone up
a lot higher a lot quicker a lot further
you know the we were told the inflation
was transitional it hasn't been trans
transitional whatever that means nobody
knows what that means yet I don't know
what it means but I do know when I went
to the grocery store and I buy a box of
groceries that was that big for $3 and I
buy the same box today it's
$4 I'm expecting that same box is going
to be 250 soon or the the quantity is
going to grow again so I do agree
representative opal wages have grown but
inflation's a hell of a lot higher than
they've been telling
us okay um representative Southworth H
thank you Mr chair I had a question for
Dr I tried to ask for Chris and he said
it really was in your area
umic oh
sorry um I just wondered on your high
estimate maybe you could tell me some of
the positives you anticipated um to come
up with the high estimate I kind of know
the negatives the reason we're looking
at the low end what did you see um that
made you do the
highend uh thank you representative
Southworth um so the commissioner spoke
to these estimates yesterday and um her
uh way of arriving at the range of 3 to
8% was to look at the past history of
the growth of the tax and she kind of
eliminated some of the highest highs and
the lowest lows and looked at the middle
of the range and the 8% was kind of the
most optimistic number she could use
when she looked at those uh rates of
past growth followup followup so it
really wasn't based on thinking certain
things were going to happen in the
future no at all there was not an
analysis of say um a particular segment
of the economy or anything like that it
was just based on past historic which
we've done in the
right but I was just curious so there
wasn't someone said a silver bullet that
you guys saw that tilted you towards the
high it was no thank you that really
helps
sure other thoughts representative elme
yes uh when was were were you looking at
the past 10 years or or what because the
last four have been totally anomalous
um I I think several of those last four
years were some of the highs that were
eliminated under her
analysis yeah
said I think she looked
back I'm going to say three or four
years prior to covid
yeah yeah uh so about to 16 I think
that's about right it sounds
right I guess before 16 you end up with
the aftermath of the Great
Recession which being a great recession
took a great long time to finish
true
thanks other thoughts on where these
estimates should end
up so R and yeah my thought is uh I
think the long-term trend lines are
pretty important here uh we're going to
have ups and downs due to oil
surprises whatever but I think the
long-term trends been fairly steady at
this uh 2 and a half% growth rate and
I've inclined to take what we've got and
look at that kind of a number going
forward
well okay so specifically what are you
talking
about not for a number oh yeah I'm I'm
just I don't have a number in mind
because I haven't done the calculation
well no well in the sense that um I
think what has been thrown out so far
was uh uh who was it representative ORS
did you put the numbers out um yeah I
why don't you to repeat the numbers that
you put out so far okay thank you Mr
chair so the numbers I put out for
1.30 26
1.12 27
1.2 okay so given that represent om
um where are you where are you in this
yeah I concur with the uh with the 2025
number 1 Point uh 03 03 right and that's
based on the analysis I'm looking at
that says growth in 25 was a little less
than grow than 24 and it's likely to go
up to more traditional levels after 2025
so I that's so I think that's a good
starting
point okay so for 2026
1.12 is
effectively um what 60 million um
90 no
1.1 so the low on 2026 is
1.06 so represent ORS is saying 1.12
which is 60 million higher so it's a
it's a growth of 60
million
um and then so forth for 2027 which
would
be no I'm sorry I was looking at the
wrong number It's one oh no no it wasn't
1.12 okay no that was right okay and one
point and you're 1.2 you're kind of kind
of in the middle uh of the range in
2027 representative Aly did you have
a uh microphone
please it looks to me like
1.12 in 26 is over 8% % growth from
1.03 1.12
1.12 I get
8.7 yes that's what I
got that seems pretty high for a year we
thought was going to be
transitional
yeah did I go that low
okay so that yeah that that's that's
assuming 8% growth
um Mr chairman it's probably optimistic
yeah yes I I think that 8% gross a
little on the high side and uh I I I
don't think that's realistic yeah what
do you think is realistic I I I think
probably more like 5% might be more
realistic over 5% over that first number
I mean because because we can think
about the economy in general a 5% growth
in in GDP is really high so probably
it's going to be closer to
3% um three two and a
half you were right take us a while to
get 1.07 okay
represent yary you have a thought on
that no 8%
High uh no what do you about think about
3% that's yeah two and a half to
3% it seems to be the trend for the
GDP uh for the last several years even
though the inflation rate has
been kind
of messing up the works as far as money
available but yeah we'll do it that way
yeah and and representative Wars in
general I don't disagree
with growth that's coming but I think
it's when is it actually coming is the
question and will it be here in 26 it'll
start but I think it's it's a slow
moving ship um so if we do oh I don't
Trump is a slow moving ship I'm talking
about the the effect the
effect okay
I'm trying to let's just see what so if
we go with representative or's initial
of
1.03 and then we multiply by
3% I want to go
four save this 1.06 09 it's did somebody
say 1.07 are you going to propose two
and a
half yeah I got 1.06 got 1.06
okay representative duet thank you and
and I I agree but maybe we can tier it a
little differently that's why I suggest
the uh 2.5 based on where GDP has been
so conservatively I'd stay at the 2.5
and if you're suggesting three I might
be able to get there but maybe we can go
to four in
2017 looking forward okay let's see what
I'm more comfortable right at that GDP
line all right it's going to take some
time and there may maybe
some uh speed bumps
yeah let's see what uh if we we start
with 1.03 and we
multiply
2.5%
.025 no that's not
right one point it's got to do one it's
got to be one one
025 1. 0557 which is
1.06 which is just like their
low uh their low is oh that is their low
okay all right so I think it's a
winner maybe we should just maybe we
should just stick with the low
too low my humble
opinion yeah but we can blame
somebody well I'm go I'm I'm okay with
changing 1.29 to
1.03 I'm sorry I didn't get Jordan's
comment
uh so let's say we we we take uh row
9ine uh and but make it 1.03 and then
row
16 I'm sorry row 11 is
1.06 no one row 11 would be 1.03 row 16
would be 1.06 right
14 oh you're right I was on the wrong
line okay so row row 11 is right
1.03 and then
row 16 is 1.06
and then what is and then now let's
discuss Road
21 no well the reason we're going what
are you talking about 27
yeah
yeah so now for 1.06 Mr chairman yeah um
if my math is right if you use the 1.06
for fiscal
26 and at I think representative duette
said he thought
4% growth in 27 four four is a bit more
optimistic I think and I think we'll be
positioned for that yeah I would agree
four that would get you to 1.1 yeah
1.124 but
1.1 okay yeah the these no one point
1.1 Z24 so just rounding
1.1 just a little bit above their the Dr
low
estimate okay so
um let's talk about Fuller Fuller
numbers here
so so basically
row so row 11 would be one
comma Z3 y
zero
26 row 16 is 1 comma
060 and
27 27 is 1 comma one0
Z no
would that's
that's the these are estimates what2 no
that the line 21 the 4% growth over one
106 was one one Z24 so 24 doesn't round
up so it should be 1 comma one
z z zero yeah one comma one z z zero
we're going out we're going out four
places so it's so one comma 1 0 0 yeah
right
yeah but what is the two that's two
that's two
million yeah okay
27 yeah I'm just saying do do we get to
that level
of
what
was
1024 yeah the four is out the four is
out okay we can do that there's another
zero in there that she's missing one one
Z2 right yeah no that's what she said
okay Mr chairman yeah I I'm just curious
because we got that one uh why wouldn't
um why wouldn't we just go with the 26
dr's low estimate of
1.06
full that I mean it's a little higher
well because you're talking about 400
thou I don't know it's that level of
accuracy
it's given this given this is an
estimate yeah that's I think not
significant every number here should
have a tiling in front
of so the the only advantage of going to
the point4 is that Finance would find a
way to work it into the budget if needed
yeah
no it's a good it's it's a reasonable
Point
yeah one Z2 yes
yes so TW line uh okay line 21 is
line 16 is
1060 and line 11 is
1030 you know honor of Representative
Wars um so given those numbers any
further discussion on these numbers
whether million bucks to
Finance on the fourth yeah on 27 we gave
him an extra 2 million
I oh represent I know I know it just
Fades um I'd just say in terms of my
personal opinion I think 2027 could go
up or down I mean I think that's going
to be year that either things are going
to get better or they're going to get
worse but I'm glad to be wrong so well
there's there's no doubt the further we
further we go out with anything uh the
further off we're going to
be and if you're yeah I always think of
the the analogy of if you're shooting at
a bullseye and the further back you go
the the slighter the the change that
will mess it up so um I think
we're yeah we're just doing the best we
can okay all right if there's no further
discussion with someone like to make a
motion on these
numbers all right tney second by
representative Aly
all right all in favor please designate
by raising your
hand represent shamberg you I don't see
your
hand all right he's afraid all right all
those
against so one again so what is the
total one two
three 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 16 to
1 hey I'm a team player I raised my hand
I I just want to congratulate the
committee I I wondered whether we could
get it done uh today this is uh you know
a lot of lot of good work and a lot of
good thought went into this um because I
was originally planning on the 19th to
to finish up anything we hadn't done now
what we'll end up doing on the 19th is
uh Chris will put together well first
first you're going to put together a new
spreadsheet for us with updated on what
we talked about today so the the next
spreadsheet you'll see will have all the
splits in it for the education trust
fund and the general fund so that'll be
presented uh I think tomorrow afternoon
after you're done your uh Bill work and
um from there I we'll have a house
resolution drafted and I'll provide that
to the chair and then at the 19th I
think he wants to um review that get the
blessing of the committee and then it
would go to the clerk to be worked into
the calendar yeah so what I'm planning
for next week is um um only having a
meeting on Wednesday the 19th um at
starting at 10
o'clock Chris we'll have the resolution
so we'll vote on the resolution which
will be presented to the to the Full
House
on whenever you know the next probably
early March yeah and um but once we vote
on it if Finance uh needs to see where
we're at we can let them know um the
other thing I I wanted to do originally
I was planning on the 19th being
finishing up what we just finished up
and
um you know may maybe executing
something but now if we're if we've got
the resolution barring any major change
between now and next Wednesday um I'll
see we may add a few extra things to
exec in there a few extra bills maybe we
can exec um the other thing is don't be
surprised when you see that I'm also
scheduling Friday it's not that I expect
to come in Friday but if it snows on
Wednesday I just want to make sure I
have a backup plan so that our revenues
get done next week because if we don't
get them done next week the following
week's vacation week which I already
said we're taking off I I don't want to
get these revenues out in March when
we're ready to go so I'll so when you
see it yes it'll be scheduled for
Wednesday and Friday but we'll only be
coming in one of those days and
hopefully it's Wednesday and then I'll
announce after that that Friday is
canceled
so only one day next week no no days the
next week this is you know we're we're
very efficient in this committee and
this is this is what happens um any
questions about what we're
doing oh I said we are very efficient in
this
committee we might be biased we might be
what's
that and maybe we're a little biased but
you know so anyways um
we thank you for the good work on this
so now at 2:00 we have an exec session
and I'm glad I scheduled for two and not
three um we have our exec session at two
we'll uh look at the four bills as
listed and then we'll be done for today
tomorrow we've got um public hearings on
I think four bills uh will'll be done or
the last public hearing is at 1 o' and
uh Chris will be in the room so that as
soon as that's finished he's going to
give us the um uh the update on the
spreadsheet and we can just eyeball it
quickly make sure we you know he didn't
make any mistakes he never does make
mistakes but there's always a first time
uh and then uh oh there was that red
herring earlier today where I didn't
have the fiscal years on that Dr page
so so um done deliberately to make sure
everyone had the chance so that's the
plan so uh we can break now and at one
at 2 o'clock we'll come back and
exac
for
e
e e
it out I'll PR it out myself
you have one sheet ready right yeah I've
got one ready for
the okay the time being 203 we're going
to get started on the executive session
I'm going to open the executive session
on HB 596 FN and represent um recognize
representative ORS for a
motion thank you Mr chairman uh I'm
making the motion to itl I'll spill 596
do I have a second
596 uh seconded by representative ducet
yeah we're doing
596 would you like to speak to your
motion representative boards uh yes uh
thank you Mr
Speaker in front of
you
so are we ready
representative ducet second
yes so uh I believe that this is going
to add additional cost to uh New
Hampshire and um in addition to that I
think it's going to place a burden on
our small
towns particularly those with uh a few
number of
facilities uh we have
a in place now if you have less than 10
facilities uh you would be exposing
yourself to your
competition so we have a cost to the
state we have cost to the small towns
which is burdensome we have the exposure
to our competition and of course then
with that is the confidentiality our
privacy which would be at risk and
therefore that's why I am recommending
we itl this legislation thank you Mr
chairman thank you anybody else wish to
speak on this representative
elme thank you um this is a major
problem for the urban hubs some of us uh
are going to be voting our
districts on this bill uh because on we
are
much uh we lose a great deal by having
these uh uh the restaurant and hotel
money uh that we have to take care of in
our districts and
also uh uh the huge number of people who
come in that require that we have two
three times as many police and too many
three times as many
EMTs uh that we are paying for um
whereas the bedroom communities do not
have to pay for any of that so um it is
a major problem it will continue to be a
major problem it will continue to show
up in one form or another and we were
hoping to try to do a retain so that we
could uh
discuss other options that did not hurt
the places that didn't have uh that were
the bedroom
communities or
the yeah that's it thank you anybody
else okay seeing no more discussion I'll
ask the clerk to call the role thank you
Mr chairman the motion before us is itl
on House Bill 596 FN
relative to reporting requirements for
entities that collect meals and rooms
taxes representative alri I
representative duet yes clerk votes yes
representative soti yes representative
ORS yes Representative Steven Smith yes
representative Tierney yes
representative by Brier yes
representative Ford yes representative
Murphy yes yes representative Aly no
representative Southworth no
representative Malloy yes Representative
shamberg no representative Bolton yes
representative John claer uh yes
representative Jeffrey Smith yes
representative
oppel hi representative Mary Harkin
Phillips no did I pronounce that correct
no my last name is representative hacken
Phillips it's like um a computer hack or
a tree hack in any CL thanks
you of of 21
votes and the 20 votes we need the
chairman to vote Yes chairman janigan
votes yes
hey I count 17 and in favor and for
opposed to that doesn't make sense no 16
16 there's only 20 of
us sorry my fingers R okay the vote
being 16 to
four the vote being 16 to4 the U bill is
itl will there be a Minority
Report the
uh represent Aly will be a Minority
Report okay so uh majority report by um
representative ORS minority by
representative aling okay and I'll close
the exact session on HB
596 so you want to make the motion to
you going to make retain
635 all right I'm going to open the exec
session on HB 635 and recognize
representative
Erie uh thank you Mr chair I would move
the committee retain this bill there's
some elements that need some discussion
and it gives a chance for uh several of
the uh multiple
email negative comments to uh uh Express
themselves more
fully I move retention do I have a
second second second by representative
sodi uh actually I already let you speak
to your motion um I'm sorry than uh any
other any other discussion on
retain seeing none or yes represent Aly
on I have je to retain on the basis that
uh you have put all of these nonprofits
in a complete dither or rather the bill
did
on a lot of them are religious a lot of
them are are doing extremely good work
with a lot of American citizens that are
being enabled to to
become uh um productive citizens
and uh you were telling them that
they've got to hang on with
this uh while
on WE satisfy on a number a small number
of the how many people was
it
that
H sorry I'm behind here but it was
hundreds of people who WR who
online uh some of them afraid to come
into the room
uh that opposed this
bill represent VY uh thank you
representative Aly U start at the end uh
if they're afraid to come into the room
that's on them not on us uh the purpose
of retention is because there are some
entities as you and previous individuals
involved including representative wer
and have looked at this uh bit about non
not for profits not being not for
profits in the a variety of different
ways over the years this just follows
the same general principle that has been
followed in the past to examine whether
or not there is a gleam of TR truth in
this uh then allegations made of some of
uh not for profits regardless of their
origin spe uh taking advantage of
current tax law for their own benefits
as opposed to actually providing a
benefit uh it's always good to take a
look at something to see whether there
is any uh fraud or waste or abuse as far
as the the keeping the entity he's on
edge uh even if we pass it in January or
pass it out uh in January and it goes on
to the floor ought to pass it still
wouldn't take effect until the next year
after uh and it still has to go to the
Senate so you
know this is there's there's time
involved one way or another as as far as
I'm concerned I think we ought to have
uh retention so that we can listen
listen to their concerns we
can take a look at some of the
allegations that were made by
individuals in good faith and make it
clear one way or another
that uh this bill should pass or should
not pass itl but the only way we can do
that with the time we have is to get it
out and by deadline this is an early
bill so by March 6th has to be reported
one of three ways this this way he gives
it a chance to take a look at it and
then report it out in uh a considered
fashion as opposed to a rapid uh example
thank you Mr chair yeah I mean I I think
one of the reasons this is being
retained is because in its current form
there are some concerns um and the um
and and when we look at the public
hearing during the public hearing we had
a vast number of people supporting the
bill I think one person opposed it now
since we have gone away from that public
hearing finished that public hearing
we've had a myriad of people against it
um where were they at that time I don't
know but that has caused us to say okay
we had all this support now we have all
this nons support let's take a look at
it and retain it and and figure it out
there there are some things that have
been brought to light that are concerns
so so um u in its current form it it
most likely will have to change
representative Opel and then
Aly I'll defer to representative Aly to
be okay
yeah my
recollection of that meeting and my
notes on that meeting were that among
the 20 people that spoke 19 of whom were
for the bill on they did didn't know the
difference between a legal migrant and
an illegal
alien they thought that refugees were
illegal they were they they wanted
refugees to be illegal they wanted
people who were waiting for asy Asylum
hearings to be
illegal um I don't I don't think we
should make judgments on the capacity of
the people that testified um
I think the at the the highest level we
know that there were a lot of people for
it and now we're getting a lot of
negative and people are making some some
points okay so let's that's that's the
reason we we're retaining it in my mind
anyone anyone
else repres
op um I guess I'm I'm missing the point
here with all due respect to my
colleague representative
oler uh the intent of this bill and the
and the vast majority of people who
testified um at our hearing were focused
on the issue of undocumented
individuals
um more than at least as I heard it more
than the issue of not for-profits it was
the idea was that there were some not
for-profits providing services to
undocumented
individuals what I'm hearing
representative ol say is that we should
be looking at not um not for-profit
organizations that are apparently taking
advantage of the tax
law um in
a
um I hate to use the word fraudulent but
that's what it sounded like he was
referring to um that seems like a
completely different issue to me and and
if someone wants to introduce a bill to
focus on that issue that's one thing but
that has nothing to do that issue
I don't really think came up during the
hearing the focus was on undocumented
individuals and
services and occasionally a situation
where um As I understood it um and an
organization like Catholic Charities
might provide one meal to an
undocumented person and and in that case
could
be um you know could be denied the uh
the 501c3 tax status or tax status in
New Hampshire um which is why I think
the move to retain this we're we're
going off in a completely different
direction the people who who testified
in support I don't think we testifying
in support of the question of the tax
status and whether organizations are
taking advantage of it
improperly thank you Mr
chairman representative
ORS thank you Mr chairman so one of the
things we learned during the
hearing was that these organizations
can immediately check to see if these
immigrants have legal or illegal status
so the concern of who they're settling
into our
community as to whether or not we're
putting undue pressure on them that that
argument goes away as we heard the other
side testify that they can uh basically
uh what do they call them they can uh
check on their I'm sorry I got a
tickle uh they can immediately verify
their immigration status so I don't see
where the unnecessary or or or pressure
or unprofessionalism would be for those
that have presented this bill and
brought it forward thank you
representative jet thank you Mr chairman
for the exact reason we're hearing all
this dialogue I understand why the
motion to retain the bill is at hand so
can we
move the question
please thank you representative uh
Aly on one of the um nonprofits that
wrote
back explained if people read it that
that system is made for whether someone
was eligible to be
hired that system was not made for
someone is allowed to be in this
country and I think that if you're going
to retain it the first thing we have to
do is get someone in to explain
that because the people that
are doing food banks and things like
that
um if we lose all of those people doing
food banks and those people providing
shelter at night in the winter uh to
people they are not capable of figuring
out if somebody is El is eligible to be
in the country they are capable only of
knowing if they're allowed to hire
them representative
YY I thank representative Aly for
bringing out the points as to exactly or
as one of the key reasons as to why we
probably need to take a long look at
this during the hearing issue issues
were
raised including the wording of the bill
if anyone takes a look at my face during
the uh testimony you'll understand there
are Parts there that I have a but
there are other parts that which we need
to take a look at the way we do that is
to retain
as the ranking member knows uh we'll
review it and then we'll make some
either uh costic or uh affirming
comments as it's recommended out of this
committee therefore I move the question
Mr
chair thank you uh with that I think uh
further discussion is going to go around
and around so I'm going to ask the clerk
to call the role thank you Mr chairman
the motion on the floor is retain on
House Bill 635 FN relative to taxing
nonprofit entities who settle illegal
immigrants as for-profit
entities representative ulri I
representative duet yes clerk fotes yes
representative soti yes representative
ORS yes representative Stevens Smith yes
representative Tierney yes
representative Brier yes representative
Ford yes representative Murphy yes
representative
Aly no representative Southworth no
representative Malloy no Representative
shamberg no representative Bolton no
Representative claer no representative
Jeffrey Smith no representative Opel no
representative Mary hackin Phillips no
chairman Jian
yes the count is
11-9 in favor of
retain okay the count the vote being 11
to9 the bill will be retained in
committee
and okay I'm going to close the public
hearing on HB 635
yeah 20 people you had 16 to
four
that's need this before noon
tomorrow h come
tomorrow no there's there's no wait a
minute there's no reports there's no
minority um there's no Minority Report
on a
retain
no Mr chair yes there's no report either
way oh there's no report either way okay
oh thank you representative save me some
work I ask for retain
minority in the fire bill it the bill is
retained it hasn't left committee yet so
the committee holds the bill and is not
reporting out you just let the clerk
know that you retained it but you don't
write an actual report okay we still
don't have that yeah there's no majority
report no Minority Report until
January thank you
okay with that I'm going to open the
executive session on HB
530 and recognize representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman thank you
colleagues I am making a motion to itl
HB 530 relative to increasing the amount
of Revenue transferred from the real
estate tax uh to the affordable housing
fund currently $5 million oh wait wait
wait I have to get a second first oh
okay Sor do I have a second
all right representative tyy second
it would you like to speak to your
motion yes thank you Mr chairman um
currently $5 million is transferred for
this purpose and this bill seeks to
raise the amount to $10 million which
would result in a reduction of
3,350 ,000 from the general fund and
$1,650,000 from the educ trust fund I
recently attended a new New Hampshire
homebuilders association meeting in
which the president revealed that the
main issue they face is not money but
rather the delay they experience due to
excessive federal and state regulations
which he claimed adds 25% to the cost of
the average single family home the real
estate trans uh the real estate transfer
tax currently funds the general fund and
the educational trust fund as I just
mentioned we're currently experiencing
pressure on both funds funds and that
there's more demand you know for these
funds uh than we can can meet so I do
not recommend we take money away from
either the general fund or the education
trust fund for the purpose of
subsidizing developers of affordable
housing it is my opinion that further
government subsidies might lead to
further inflation of construction and
loss of other government services that
currently the education trust fund and
general fund are providing thank you
thank you other comments
yes represent
opal um thank you Mr chairman I I've
heard an awful lot about regulation
being the the chief factor
in uh the housing the current housing
crisis um but we have a housing crisis
in my district in Kanan Dorchester and
orange um Kanan the largest of those
communities my hometown
does not have comprehensive
zoning um the only requirements we have
are the State Building Code which is
essentially uh a fire and safety code at
its most
Elemental um things like requiring smoke
detectors to help keep people alive um I
don't think and I I I don't disagree
that there are issues with regulation
uh there are delays in in other places
but I'm not sure that it is the only or
the even the chief issue I do think the
availability of additional funds to the
Hampshire Housing
Organization um a lot of the housing
that's going up to any degree is not
Workforce housing is not housing for
middle class families it is um far too
expensive for the median wage earner in
this state um so I'm going to oppose
this this motion and I I just say I
think um the issue in this case clearly
is one of additional funds um I I am
hesitant to withdraw money from the
education trust fund but I think in this
case um people need a place to live
first thank you Mr
chairman any other
comments okay seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the
role thank you Mr chairman the motion is
itl on house bill 530 FN increasing the
amount of Revenue transferred from the
real estate transfer tax to the
affordable housing fund representative
ulri I representative ducet yes clerk
votes yes representative soti yes
representative ORS yes Representative
Steven Smith yes representative Tierney
yes representative Brier yes
representative Ford yes representative
Murphy yes representative
Aly representative Southworth no
representative Malloy no Representative
shamberg no representative Bolton no
Representative cluder no representative
Jeffrey Smith no representative Opel no
representative Mary hackin Phillips no
chairman janigian yes
16 correction 19 to 11
to9 11 votes in favor nine
opposed okay with the vote 11 to9 the um
itl passes
uh let's see
the is there going to be a Minority
Report opal
okay uh let me think about it I I don't
know
yet I'm going to close you exact session
on HB 530
okay I'm going to open the exec session
on HB
591 and recognize representative
Ford um I move to OTP House Bill
591 uh which is expanding the hours for
The Kino gaming on weekends do I have a
second second by representative
Aly and would you like to speak to your
motion yes um um I moved to do this
because it adds six additional hours
across
280 approximately 280 retailers and the
lottery anticipates an increase of
1.5% uh for approximately 865,000
okay that was that was easy uh I'll ask
the clerk to call the rooll thank you Mr
chairman the vote the motion is ought to
pass on House Bill 591 FN expanding
hours for Keno gaming on
weekends representative
Oli I
guess yes representative duet yes clerk
votes yes representative so yes
representative ORS yes Representative
Steven Smith yes representative Tierney
yes representative Brier yes
representative Ford yes representative
Murphy yes representative
Aly no I know this sounds a little weird
I thought I heard
itl that's all right is that is that is
there a problem with that
this motion is ought to pass
representative Aly she said no no no
thank you representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy no Representative
shamberg no representative Bolton yes
representative
cluder yes representative Jeffrey Smith
yes representative
Opel I representative Mary hackin
Phillips
no chairman
janigian
yes we have
16-4 16 in favor four
opposed okay the vote being 16 to4 um
OTP
passes Minority Report uh representative
Al
me no Minority Report okay figur they
didn't even to come
in okay uh with that I will close the
exec session on HB
591 and that concludes
uh today's exec
session um we made uh incredible timing
today getting the uh Revenue estimates
done and this all by 230 I thank the
committee we're not we're not done yet
uh I thank the committee for their good
work on this uh and as I said tomorrow
we'll have uh our public hearings four
public hearings and the last one
starting at 1 o'clock we should finish
around 1:30ish somewhere in there cruset
will present the updated um spreadsheet
on what we um pass
today and uh just to repeat one last
time next week I plan to have a a uh
final Revenue session on um the N
Wednesday the 19th so we can uh and
Chris will bring a resolution at that
time and we'll EXA the resolution and
then maybe exec a couple more bills I
will also schedule a meeting on Friday
which I hope will be
unnecessary um it's only a backup in
case it snows pretty much at this point
any
questions all right thank you everyone
see you
soon
e e